[Musique]
l'exposition même vient de m'étonner
beaucoup comme vous même car nous avons
vu ces objets depuis longtemps au caire
mais enfin nous ne les avions pas vu
dans d'autres conditions et ce qui
paraît ici dans cette présentation si
particulière c'est incroyable leçon que
l'egypte aura pu donner sur la vie on a
écrit depuis champollion que c'était le
pays demeure ces terres qui est si
souvent s'uniraient on est à peu près
jamais proprement finnair autrement dit
l'egypte n'a jamais connu le skate ce
qu'elle allait chercher dans la mort
c'était précisément la suppression de la
mort le fait de concevoir la vie humaine
comme une éternité
[Musique]